I was born in 1934 one of a pair of
twins Miriam and I were the certain
ports children in the family we lived in
a very small village in Transylvania
Romania
[Music]
[Applause]
we got them from the cattle car people
were selected to live or to die people
crying pushing shoving
dogs barking trying to make some sense
of that place and I actually turned
around in trying to figure out what is
it I've never seen a place like that
before and as I turned around I realized
that my father and my two older sisters
were gone never saw them again we were
holding on to mother for dear life and
not he was running in the middle of that
selection platform yelling in German
twins twins he noticed us and demanded
to know if we were twins my mother asked
is that good and the Nazi said yes my
mother said yes at that moment another
Nazi came pulled my mother to the right
we were pulled to the left we were
crying she was crying and alive I
remember is seeing my mother's arms
stretched out in this parish she was
pulled away I never even said goodbye to
her but I did not understand that this
would be the last time that we would see
her and all that took 30 minutes from
the time with that done from the cattle
car and my whole family was gone
only Miriam and I were left holding
hands and cried we were Mengele twins
which we found out later on what that
meant
[Music]
Mangala would count us every morning and
he wanted to know how many guinea pigs
he had this day I was used in two types
of experiments Monday Wednesday Friday
they would put me naked in a room with
my twin sister and many other twins up
to eight hours a day they would measure
every part of my body compare it to my
twin sister and then compare it to chart
on alternate days Tuesday Thursday
Saturday they would take us to a blood
lab they would tie both of my arms to
restrict the blood flow take a lot of
blood from my left arm and give me a
minimum of five injections in the writer
the content of those injections we
didn't know then not doing now today
after one of those injections I became
very ill with a very high fever my legs
and arms were swollen and very painful I
was trembling as the August Sun was
burning my skin and I had huge red spots
covering my body the next visit is a
blood leg they didn't tie my arms
instead of that measure my fever and I
was immediately taken to the hospital
the hospital was another barrack but it
was filled with people who looked me
more dead than alive
next morning Mangala came in was four of
the doctors never ever examined me he
looked at my favorite chart and then he
declared too bad she's so young she has
only two weeks to live for the following
two weeks I have only one clear memory
crawling on the barrack floor because I
no longer could walk and crawling to
reach apposite with water at the other
end of the barrack and as I was crawling
I would fade out in and out of
consciousness telling myself I must
survive I must survive after two weeks
my favor broke and I felt immediately a
lot stronger it took me another three
weeks before my fever charge of normal
Miriam and I got back she was sitting on
the bed staring into space when I asked
her what happened to you she said I
cannot talk about it I will not talk
about it
and we didn't talk about Auschwitz until
1985
[Music]
and I asked her in 85 Miriam do you
remember when I was taken to the
hospital she said yes I said what
happened to you while I was in the
hospital she said I was under Nazi
doctors supervision 24 hours a day it
was the same two weeks that Mangala said
I would die so I said to him what
happened to you after the two weeks were
up she said she was taken back to the
labs injected with many injections that
made her feel very sick as I found out
years later and she grew up got married
in Israel expected her first child she
developed severe kidney infections that
did not respond to any antibiotic second
pregnancy in 63 the infection got so bad
that the Israeli doctor studied her and
they found out that Miriam's kidneys
never grew larger they're the size of a
ten-year-old child so I begged Miriam
that not to have any more children
because every pregnancy were the life
crisis but she had a third child and
after the search child was born her
kidneys deteriorated started to
deteriorate and by 1987 they failed at
which time I donated my left kidney I
had two kidneys and one sister so it was
an easy choice but a year later she
developed cancerous polyps in the
bladder the doctors kept asking me to
find our office files we never found our
files we never found out what was
injected into our bodies Miriam died
June 6 1993 months after Miriam died
the telephone call from a professor and
master who said he heard me speak and he
would like me to go to Boston and speak
and when I came there it would be nice
if I could bring a naughty laughter I
was stunned at such a question
and when I thought about it I remembered
that the last project that Miriam and I
worked together before she died was 1992
and for the documentary done by a German
television about the Mangala twins and
in that documentary
there was a Nazi doctor from Auschwitz
and I figured the fever of the life in
92 he might be alive in 93 so I got his
telephone number I called him and
invited him to Boston
when he told me was not going to go to
Boston but he was willing to meet with
me at his house in Germany I think then
didn't plan to ask him any of these
questions suddenly I am asking you were
in Auschwitz did you ever walk by gas
chamber did you ever go inside the gas
chamber do you know how the gas chamber
operated listen this is the nightmare
that I live with every single day of my
life and when I'm describing the
operation of the gas stream but he was
stationed outside looking through a
peephole while the gas was coming down
and people were dying then everybody was
dead then nobody moved he knew that they
were dead and assigned one death
certificate no names just the number of
people that were murdered and I asked
him to go with me to Auschwitz in 1995
then we would observe 50 years of the
liberation of the camp because I wanted
him to sign a document just what he told
me but I wanted it signed at the rise of
the gas-turbine our friends and he
agreed immediately I will have an
original document
signed by a Nazi and if I ever met a
revisionist who said the Holocaust
didn't happen I could take that document
and shove it in their face
I wanted to sink this Nazi doctor from
his willingness to document against
another operation I didn't know how to
center nothing I didn't tell anybody
about it
because even to me it sounded strange I
didn't want anybody to change my mind
after 10 months one morning I woke up
and the following simple idea popped
into my head how about a letter of
forgiveness from me the doctor which I
knew immediately that he would like it
and that was the meaningful gift a oash
with survivor gives him a letter of
forgiveness there nothing after but what
I discovered for myself was
life-changing an discovered that I had
the power to forgive no one could give
me that power no one could take it away
it was all mine to use in any way I
wished and that became an interesting
thing because as a victim of almost 50
years I never saw that I had any power
over my life now I began writing a
letter and I didn't know how to write a
letter of forgiveness and it took me
four months to write it and then I
thought somebody might read it
and I my diction in English is good my
spelling is not so I wanted my former
English professor to correct my family
so I called her we met three times and
third time she said to me not even ice
you forgive this doctor much your
problem is not with doctor much your
problem is with dr. Mandela I was not
quite ready to forgive megalo she said
to me okay
I have been meeting with you correcting
your letter now I want you to do me a
favor when you go home tonight pretend
that Mengele is in the room and you are
telling him that you forgive him I want
to find out how would it make you feel
if you could do that
interesting ideas odd and when I got
home actually I did something else I
picked up a dictionary and wrote down 20
nestea words which I read clear and loud
does that make believe mangle in the
room and at the end I said in spite of
all that I forgive you made me feel very
good that eyes a little guinea pig of 50
years even had the power over the Angel
of Death of Auschwitz so that is the way
we arrived in Auschwitz dr. munch came
with his son daughter and granddaughter
I took my son and my daughter
I read my declaration of amnesty which
is a very good include document and I
signed it dr. munch scientist document I
felt free free from Auschwitz free from
Mengele so now that I have forgiven him
I knew that most of the survivors
denounced me and they denounced me today
also but what is my forgiveness I like
it it is an act of self healing
self-liberation self empowerment all
victims all hurt
till hopeless feel helpless feel
powerless I want everybody to remember
that we can not change what happened
that is a tragic part but we can change
how we relate to it
[Music]